dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IIFA here not so
long ago open AI has released GPT to an
AI that was trained to look at a piece
of text and perform common natural
language processing operations on it
for instance answering questions
summarization and more but today we are
going to be laser focused on only one of
those tasks and that task is
continuation where we give an AI a bunch
of texts and we ask it to continue it
however as these learning algorithms are
quite general by design here comes the
twist who said that this can only work
for text why not try it on composing
music so let's have a look at some
results we're only the first six notes
were given from a song and the AI was
asked to continue it
[Music]
love it
this is a great testament to the power
of general learning algorithms as you've
heard this works great for a variety of
different runners as well and not only
that but it can also create really cool
blends between genres listen as the AI
starts out from the first six nodes of a
Chopin piece and transitions into a pop
style with a bunch of different
instruments entering a few seconds in
[Music]
and great news because if you look here
we can try our own combinations through
an online demo as well on the left side
we can specify and here the short input
sample and ask for a variety of
different styles for the continuation it
is amazing fun try it I've put a link in
the video description I was particularly
impressed with this combination
really cool now this algorithm is also
not without limitations as it has
difficulties pairing instruments that
either don't go too well together or
there is lacking training data on how
they should sound together the source
code is also either already available as
of the publishing of this video or will
be available soon if so I will come back
and update the video description with
the link open AI has also published an
almost to our concert with tons of
different genres so make sure to head to
the video description and check it out
yourself
I think these techniques are either
already so powerful or will soon be
powerful enough to raise important
copyright questions and will need plenty
of discussions on who really owns this
piece of music what do you think let me
know in the comments thanks for watching
and for your generous support and I'll
see you next time